Big Fish was founded 15 years ago as a simple game studio.
We have become with time an important company in developing
Mobile games for several platforms.
We've been designing Android games since it was launched.
It was great to see how focused developers' tools were
And global reach
Which helped us deliver better games to a larger audience.
It is a wonderful thing now that we can use
Tools such as Open Beta for experimental use
To gather information that allows us to make a greater effort
In the development of user-focused design.
The games were previously subject to trial release
A process that was very satisfactory to us,
We were just waiting to make sure all the features were available
The game is published.
Now we use Open Beta
We really want to put the game directly to users
More early during the process.
Cooking Craze is a time management game,
Where the game is played from the perspective of the chef.
Posted Big Fish Cooking Craze
Working with a partner called ElaFun who developed it.
This is the first time we offer a free time management game
The experience was very enjoyable and impressed the players.
When comparing the launch of previous games
With the latest launch of Cooking Craze
Open Beta was used
We noticed a significant reduction in the crash rate
About 21%.
And we also got a larger amount
Of the comments, about 10 fold.
We have also noted,
Based on a larger sample size, no
1 or 2 star ratings in Cooking Craze.
In the previous game version,
We got a few outstanding comments.
Advantages of using Open Beta
You can still play games globally.
This allows the marketing team to improve their operations,
Acquisition partners and paid campaigns
Which was not available to them at the initial launch via GeoLock.
Before using Open Beta, we were launching games empirically
In a few initial launch countries,
We used that process to find out all the metrics
Which we are looking for.
With Open Beta, we can launch the game globally immediately,
We can collect data from a wider range
Of players that express more accurately
What we will see when the game officially launched.
With Open Beta, we no longer assume any restrictions.
What we have to do is launch the game and publish it and observe what happens,
We can interact in the event of a problem
Rather than assuming a problem occurs.
We check the key performance indicators of the game,
Take a look at the team that offers the game
And on the scale of its capabilities.
We look at a lot of metrics
In Android dynamic cursors.
In the pilot release,
Take a look at retention rates.
Users return to the game on the second day
Or on the third day?
We usually check the retention rate of D1, D7 and D30.
Then take a look at the metrics for making a material profit.
If the metrics are satisfactory to us,
Realize that it is time to move on
Official launch phase.
We have increased retention rates
Significantly.
Where the retention rate D1 increased by about nine percentage points,
The D7 rate increased by about eight percentage points,
The D30 rate is about 5 percentage points.
One of the great features of Open Beta
We can collect comments
Of the experimental players without appearing
Comments and ratings for all users.
Now if we fail something, we will not get negative feedback
Remain in our permanent record
During the game life cycle.
I recommend all game developers
Take a look at the tools in Play Console.
Because we use a lot of these tools and take advantage of them too.
During the past year alone, we changed the way
The development of games and the issuance of a large,
Depending on Open Beta only.